قالت الوكاله الاوكرانيه للطاقه الذريه ان
الرفايل الجروسي رئيس الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه وصل الى محطه النوويه في
ثالث زياره من نوعها وذلك منذ سيطره
القوات الروسيه عليها
وكان جروسي قد صرح عقب تفجير سد كخوفكا ان
الوكاله تعتزم مواصله جولات التفتيش في
المحطه من جهته قال رئيس الهيئه النوويه
الروسيه عندما محطه النوويه تعمل بشكل
طبيعي ورغم وضعها الحالي يتم ضمانه سلامه
العمل فيها
اود ان اسالك عن اعلان الخارجيه الروسيه
عن اجراء مباحثات مع واشنطن مؤخرا تطرقت
لمساله تنظيم الاسلحه النوويه
نعم عثمان يمكن اعتبار هذه الاتصالات
المباشره هي الاتصالات الاولى من نوعها
منذ اعلان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
في 21 من فبراير الماضي عن وقف روسيا
التزامها بمعاهده ستارت للحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه النوويه
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي قال بان رغم
هذه الاتصالات المباشره التي جاءت خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره فان مواقف روسيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بشان معاهده
ستارت ما زالت غير متوافقه لكنه اكد في
المقابل على التوصل الى اتفاق بين جانبين
يخص مساله تواصل تبادل الاختارات عند
التجارب تجارب الاطلاق اطلاق الصواريخ
الباليستيه وايضا عند التدريبات العسكريه
للقوات الاستراتيجيه طبعا روسيا ما زالت
على موقفها الذي ير انه من المستبعد
العوده الى الاتزان بهذه الاتفاقيه
النوويه الهامه بين البلدين الا اذا ما
قامت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بين
قوسين من بيئه التخلي عن نهجها المعادي
لروسيا هذا ما اكدت عليه ايضا المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه ماريا اليوم قالت بان ذلك
ممكن فقط اذا ما اتخذت واشنطن الخطوات
لخفض التصعيد وهنا في اشاره مباشره الى
وقف دعم
الجيش الاوكراني بالسلاح واتخاذ خطوات
لدفع ايضا الجانب الاوكراني الى الدخول في
مفاوضات مع الجانب الروسي وفق حقائق
يعني مستجدات جديده كما قالت زخاربها من
بينها الالتزام بعدم الانضمام مستقبلا الى
النيتو الحفاظ على الوضع الحيادي للدوله
الاوكرانيه ايضا خلوها من اي اسلحه نوويه
والاعتراف بالاراضي التي ضمتها روسيا وفق
وضعك الراهن الاعتراف ايضا كما قالت
بحقوق السكان الناطقين باللغه الروسيه
ووقف الاعمال القتاليه من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني اضافه الى وقف الجيش الاوكراني
ماده عفوا الدول الغربيه ماده جيش
الاوكراني بالاسلحه ايضا هذه هي رؤيه
موسكو ليس فقط للعوده الى هذه الاتفاقيه
الهامه بين البلدين بل لاي تسويه مستقبليه
في خدم هذا طبعا التباعد في وجهه نظر بين
موسكو والدول الغربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكم راسل الجزيره امين